c'est au service de cette ambition que
le groupe canal+ est complètement
réinventé depuis nos derniers échanges
en 2016
en france où les chaînes canal+ ont
perdu et je veux être précis sur ce
sujet
452 millions d'euros sur la période 2014
2015 nous avons entamé un plan
d'économies le plus de 2 milliards qui
nous a permis d'investir massivement
dans la création
de diviser par deux le prix d'accès à
canal+ pour retrouver la compétitivité
de lancer de nouvelles offres digitales
à moins de 10 euros pour séduire les
plus jeunes et de transformer le modèle
de canal+ en distributeurs
d'applications puisque nous avons agrégé
successivement netflix puis disney + et
plus récemment star plaît
surtout le groupe canal+ s'est
internationalisé
la vidéo par abonnement est un marché de
coûts fixes il y a donc un enjeu de
taille critique pour l'ensemble des
acteurs afin de mieux amortir les coûts
plus un opérateur à d'abonnés - le prix
de revient par abonné d'une série d'un
film est important
prenez par exemple films netflix dit
irishman de scorsese au budget de 150
millions de dollars pour netflix avec
222 millions d'abonnés cela revient à 60
centimes par abonné pour canal+ cela
reviendrait à 6 euros 20 par abonné
c'est pourquoi les plateformes
américaines se sont mondialisés
ce défi de la taille le groupe canal+
lanparty relevé depuis 2016 nous avons
doublé le nombre de nos abonnés en cinq
ans en passant de 11 millions en 2015 à
près de 22 millions d'abonnés en 2020
dans plus de 40 pays à travers le monde
et sur ses 22 millions d'abonnés plus de
treize sont désormais hors de france
nous avons doublé le nombre de nos
abonnés en europe
tripler le nombre de ses abonnés en
afrique est largement franchi la barre
du million d'abonnés en asie
nous nous sommes dans le même temps
digitalisées avec notre application my
canal nous investissons chaque année
plus de 100 millions d'euros dans le
développement de cet actif nos logiques
clés et nous avons déployé cet actif
dans une grande partie nos territoires à
travers le monde
enfin nous avons renforcé nos
investissements dans les contenus le
coeur du réacteur comme en témoigne la
montée en puissance de studiocanal qui
produit et distribue une trentaine de
films par an dans le monde les films
anglais et allemands mais aussi les plus
grands succès du cinéma français comme
le démontrent les succès public et
critique de bac nord boîtes noires et de
son vivant et leurs treize nominations
aux césars reçu avant-hier
studio canal s'est également renforcée
dans les séries avec une trentaine de
fictions produites et distribuées chaque
année grâce à nos neuf sociétés de
productions européennes en france mais
aussi en angleterre en espagne en
pologne en allemagne au danemark
nous développons également de plus en
plus de fictions d'ambitions
internationales pour canal+ le plus
souvent ancrés en france comme
versailles baron noir valider ou encore
hippocrate elles sont en large majorité
produit par des sociétés de production
indépendantes
à titre d'exemple une seule création
originale a été produite par studio
canal en france en 2021 sur les neuf que
nous avons diffusé
nos investissements dans le sport ont
également fortement augmenté ces
dernières années le renouvellement du
top 14 jusqu'en 2027 en est l'une des
dernières illustrations
canal+ est devenu en 2021 le premier
diffuseur mondial de la ligue des
champions
et enfin notre nouvel accord avec les
organisations du cinéma en france
prévoit un investissement minimum de
canal+ dans le cinéma français et
européen de plus de 600 millions d'euros
sur les trois prochaines années
au global nous aurons investi 3,4
milliards d'euros dans la création et
les contenus en 2021
j'aimerais souligner que ce projet
économique est rentable et rationnelle
notre résultat opérationnel est passé de
281 millions d'euros en 2016 à 477
millions d'euros en 2020 ces résultats
sont quasi exclusivement porté par nos
activités à l'international
au moins aussi important la satisfaction
de nos abonnés n'a jamais été aussi
élevée sur les cinq dernières années et
l'image de la marque canal + s'est
considérablement renforcée nous sommes
la seule marque française dans
classement brandz heinz 2021 des marques
médias mondiales les plus valorisées
nous avons également été élue pour la
troisième année consécutive entreprises
préférées des étudiants et jeunes
diplômés dans la catégorie média en
france
cette excellence opérationnelle nous a
permis d'obtenir la confiance et le
soutien total de notre actionnaire
vivendi nous a ainsi accompagner notre
développement en nous soutenant sur
plusieurs investissements majeurs
l'acquisition pour plus de 1 milliard
d'euros du groupe emme seven opérateurs
de télévision payante dans sept pays
d'europe de l'est
l'acquisition récente de spa
international éditeur de chaînes cinéma
dans 30 pays et nous sommes devenus le
premier actionnaire de multichoice le
leader de la télévision payante en
afrique anglophone et lusophone
mais malgré tout cela notre position
reste marginal au niveau mondial sur le
marché de la vidéo par abonnement no 22
millions d'abonnés doit se comparer aux
222 netflix aux plus de 200 millions d'
amazon et aux 118 millions de disney
plus
en 2020 nous avons certes réussi
l'exploit d'enregistrer une croissance
nette de parcs de 260 milles abonnés en
france mais dans le même temps des flics
sont gagnés 2 millions
en regardant ces équilibres
concurrentiel je me demande simplement
si la concentration en france et le
coeur du sujet
j'ai pu constater que le dispositif
anti-concentration domestique utilisé à
plein était jusqu'à présent efficaces
pour réguler les consolidations dans les
médias
nous avons nous-mêmes été régulier sur
l'ensemble de nos métiers pour
l'acquisition de tps pendant plus de
treize ans et certains engagements
perdure même jusqu'en 2024 pour les
autres maires soit 17 ans après la
fusion
par ailleurs force est de constater
comme l'a fait monsieur olivier mestre
président de l'art comme que le marché
français est moins concentré que par le
passé
en télévision nous sommes ainsi passés
de 3 chaînes publiques dans les années
80 à 30 chaînes nationales aujourd'hui
sur la tnt et 230 sur les autres modes
de diffusion
toutes les voix s'expriment aujourd'hui
en france est ce plus que jamais
une fois ce constat effectué et je
terminerai par là reste une question
importante peut-on trouver les modèles
créer des ensembles qui coexiste avec
ces géants mondiaux je suis convaincu
que nous en avons la capacité
les acteurs français sont bien leaders
mondiaux du luxe de l'aéronautique ou
des cosmétiques pourquoi n'en serait-il
pas de même pour la culture
vivendi et canal+ sont prêts à relever
ce défi canal+ est présent dans plus de
50 pays j'ai annoncé récemment un
objectif de 30 millions d'abonnés
minimum d'ici à 2025
nous avons fait la démonstration que des
contenus européens pouvaient connaître
un énorme succès à l'international avec
le bureau des légendes ou pas digne
tonnes pendant citer que deux
mais il ne faut pas nous entraver
davantage
il existe déjà beaucoup d'asymétrie avec
les acteurs globaux des écarts de
puissance financière bien sûr mais
surtout des asymétries normative liés
aux obligations d'investissement dans la
création encore aux obligations de
diffusion
il bénéficie de par leur taille et leur
plasticité d'une capacité à se
développer mondialement de façon
opportuniste en lissant les contraintes
qu'ils peuvent éventuellement trouver
dans tel ou tel pays
il existe aujourd'hui beaucoup de freins
à l'internationalisation des acteurs
français à commencer par la non
détention des droits des oeuvres
audiovisuelles qui financent quasi tra
intégralement le sénat je connais ce
sujet
nous n'avons pas les mêmes moyens et
nous ne jouons pas avec les mêmes règles
le risque est contré temps une
hypothétique concentration nationale
nous rendions plus complexe encore le
développement de nos fleurons nationaux
à l'étranger je le redis la culture
française est un atout majeur elle
fascine monde entier il s'agit d'une
chance que nous avons décidé de saisir
efforts de nos succès récents une
aventure qui nous anime et nous porte
chez canal+
je me tiens à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions merci messieurs
ça va les premières questions vont
arriver avec celle de david assouline
merci ce saada de nous avoir exposé
votre parcours et et les résultats
de votre groupe nous en particulier dans
le domaine
de la vidéo et
du cinéma
et tout le monde c'est en france
que notamment le cinéma
repose
sur une jambe
sur deux jambes mais sur ton dont l'une
et canal+ et
nous sommes toujours attentifs dans la
au sénat et dans la commission des
affaires culturelles au fait que cet
investissement qui a été à la base même
de votre création et des droits que vous
avez acquis grâce à cet engagement
puisse perdurer
mais vous savez très bien et le
président l'a dit en entrée que ce sujet
de la concentration pour nous
va dans deux directions
une direction vous avez traité avec un
point de vue
la concentration au niveau économique
avec cet argument de faire face aux
grandes plate-formes dans un marché
mondialisé
vous prouvez d'ailleurs par tout ce que
vous avez développé
et en nous assurant que votre groupe vit
bien et se développe que il ya moyen
sans ressembler à ces plateformes de
vivre et de faire même des bénéfices
mais vous avez un point de vue et c'est
un point de vue économique que nous
allons traiter avec avantages
inconvénients
nécessitait de grands investissements
dans un domaine où ça coûte cher la
production et la distribution dans cet
environnement et la nécessité de
maintenir une diversité et un pluralisme
de l'offre tant sur le plan culturel
puisque vous parlez de culture française
mais dans cette culture française ce qui
est peut-être le plus marquant dans ce
que nous revendiquons par rapport à
d'autres pays c'est justement son sa
diversité et est
donc c'est important de pouvoir la
maintenir mais aussi dans le domaine de
l'information ça vous n'avez absolument
rien dit des problématiques que des
groupe g en
verticaux
possédant de façon aussi horizontale
nombreux médias
pas seulement
télévisée mais aussi radio est écrit et
dans le domaine de l'édition et dans le
domaine de la publicité ce qui fait
quand même une chaîne peuvent en quoi ça
peut atteindre à cette diversité
pluralisme et liberté des journalistes
et de l'information alors j'ai
une première question parce que
voilà on a la chance ici de pouvoir
auditionner tout le monde
parce que c'est un devoir de venir et
donc on a pu auditionner
votre propriétaire on va dire monsieur
bolloré comme on le fait pour tous les
autres groupes et c'est l'originalité de
ses auditions aussi c'est que des
personnalités qui parle peu viennent
répondre et dire ce qu'elles ont à dire
et ce qui était très marquants et
relever c'est que il a dit moi je
n'interviens dans rien
rien il ya des gens compétents pour cela
et notamment vous alors
j'espère que là on va avoir les réponses
la charte la convention qui vous lie
au csa pour ses news qui est une des
chaînes de votre groupe qu'on n'allait
même pas évoquée alors vous savez que
c'est comme un mot au coeur de
l'attention de tout le monde puisqu'il
s'agit de l'information dit la chose
suivante
l'éditeur assure le pluralisme de
l'expression des courants de pensée et
d'opinion notamment dans le cas des
recommandations formulées par le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel
et notamment ce qui concerne le
pluralisme politique mais le plus aura
une vue comme
plus générale
il dit ensuite
l'éditeur veille dans son programme à ne
pas inciter à des pratiques ou
comportements dangereux délinquants ou
inciviques respecter les différentes
sensibilités politiques culturelles et
religieuses du pays à ne pas encourager
des comportements discriminatoires en
raison de la race ou de l'origine du
sexe de l'orientation sexuelle de la
religion de la nationalité à promouvoir
les valeurs d'intégration et de
solidarité qui sont celles de la
république et lutter contre les
discriminations
donc c'est très précis très clair et
vous savez que et par des mises en
demeure et par des mises en garde
nombreuses puisque vous avez le record
avec cette chaîne notamment mais en
général
beaucoup voit notamment avec la façon
dont a été mis sur orbite monsieur
zemmour qui maintenant est candidat à la
présidentielle et non pas président que
monsieur bolloré l'a dit
que beaucoup de témoignages beaucoup de
faits rapportés par la presse montrent
qu' il y a une volonté de en faire une
chaîne d'opinion or ce que je viens de
vous lire
interdit en tous les cas écarte toute
possibilité que votre chaîne
d'information puisse est une chaîne
d'opinion que me répondez vous à cette
remarque
selon le rapporteur je vais déjà vous
remercier pour vos mots sur le cinéma en
effet parce que je me souviens que lors
de l'audition 2007 vous aviez exprimé
des inquiétudes sur le sujet et sur un
retrait possible de canal plus
et on déplie de d'efforts de certains et
de ce que nous considérons comme un
quasi favoritisme des plateformes
américaines dans les démarches qui ont
été entreprises parfois par le
gouvernement on a démontré notre
attachement au cinéma français on s'est
engagé sur un investissement supérieur à
tout ce qu'on a fait dans le passé et on
est le jeu le rappelle le seul acteur
abordé aujourd'hui des engagements de
diversité puisqu'on parle de diversité
culturelle
avec les 200 millions que nous
investissons que nous investirons
parents sont plus de 170 sur canal+ plus
de
plus de la moitié des films de la
diversité à moins de 4 millions d'euros
plus d'un tiers des films des premiers
ou deuxièmes films et pour beaucoup des
films qui ne sont soutenus par aucune
chaîne hertzienne qui n'existeraient pas
sans canal +
alors sur ses news je les ai pas
mentionné j'ai pas mentionner toutes les
chaînes ce serait très long
payante
0 6%
et 0 4% du chiffre d'affaires du groupe
canal+ je je je suis d'abord un
gestionnaire et je consacre l'essentiel
de mon temps aux sujets qui ont le plus
d'impact économique sur sur le groupe
canal plus est il est vrai que je me
suis pas
épanché sur sur la chaîne d'information
qui représente moins de 0 5 % de notre
chiffre d'affaires
sur les mises en demeure alors oui on
peut pas reprocher au csa de ne pas
s'occuper de seignosse francs
avec des innovations assez régulière
comme des mises en demeure préventive
sur le temps de parole avant même que
les périodes
soit écoulée c'était une première
d'ailleurs on a fait la démonstration au
31 décembre qu'on avait parfaitement
respecté les temps de parole je le
rappelle lorsqu'on parle beaucoup de et
beaucoup de faits comme vous dites
beaucoup de choses qui sont rapportés
dans la presse mais moi je regarde la
réalité des choses et la réalité des
choses c'est qu'au 31 décembre nous
avons respecté le temps de parole en
dépit de cette ces mises en demeure
inédite 1 inédite préventive sur avant
que la période soit écoulé c'était quand
même assez assez intéressant et je
profite pour vous donner le relevé du
csa sur la période du 1er janvier au 16
janvier 2022 qui vient de s'écouler
6h49 de temps de parole pour emmanuel
macron et ses soutiens sur ses news
c'est plus que bfm 5h20 c'est trois fois
plus que france info 12h29 seule valérie
pécresse est devant sur ces news sur
cette période jean luc mélenchon est
troisième avec 6h23 et eric zemmour est
quatrième avec 5h09
5h09 de temps parole pour examiner ses
soutiens sur ses news c - bfmtv qui fait
6h19 et c'est à peu près la même chose
que lci sur la période
ça c'est sur le temps de parole en temps
d'antenne lci est loin devant ces news
8h42 et bfm 7h46 avec 10h46 d'antenne
sur eric zemmour ça c'est sur la période
qui vient de s'écouler
repréciser la période 1er au 16 janvier
2022 oui
la dernière c'est les chiffres du csa
juste une remarque comme ça
on avance
bien entendu vous parlez des quinze
derniers jours quoi en fait non j'ai
aussi parlé de la période du 31 décembre
qui s'est écoulé à la fin de l'année
dernière sur lesquels on avait une mise
en demeure présente et vous avez noté
nous avons respecté le temps de parole
nous avons systématiquement respecté
menant parole on nous a jugés avant que
la période soit écoulé s'est encore une
fois c'est une première la même façon
que le csa nous a indiqué qu'il y avait
un sujet sur le temps de parole qui
était qui se passait pendant la nuit ils
étaient une pratique absolument courante
de toutes les chaînes d'information
c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de règles sur
ce sujet là qu'à partir du moment où le
csa a indiqué qu'il y avait un sujet là
dessus nous nous sommes conformés c'est
compliqué de se conformer à des règles
avant même que les périodes soit soit
écoulé mais le csa il me semble par
rapport à ce que vous dites sur est ce
que ces news respecte la convention
clairement je respecte je dis que oui et
il me semble qu'on peut pas taxer le csa
de laxisme en ce qui concerne cette news
vous l'avez dit vous-même nous faisons
manifestement nous attirons beaucoup
l'attention du csa qui passent beaucoup
de temps devant les antennes de ses news
il croyait bien s'ils avaient quelque
chose à nous à nous reprocher il aurait
fait je je continue là dessus après j'ai
une question plus globale de
sur les le type de concentration
verticale notamment le rôle d'ava c'est
de la publicité qui qui est un sujet qui
a émergé dans cette commission et qui
est son intérêt avec aussi le lien avec
l'édition mais plus concrètement
vous ne pouvez pas réduire la convention
que je viens de lire au respect du temps
d'antenne politique est très réglementée
notamment à partir du 1er janvier quand
vous citez ces chiffres précis où il y à
des obligations très claires
parce qu'on rentre dans une période de
campagne présidentielle
où on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi
donc j'ai étendu mon propos
en lisant la convention
et je vous ai posé une question très
clair sur chaîne d'opinion ou pas chaîne
d'opinions tout ce qui est fait depuis
maintenant un bon bout de temps
sur ces news en termes de choix de
débatteur terme de thématiques en termes
d'éditoriaux et
en affichage revendiquer
de ce qui anime les émissions
le caractère des invités qui n'avaient
pas leur place sur les plateaux de
télévision parce que le négationnisme
et des théories racistes n'avaient pas
leur place sur les plateaux de
télévision de chaînes d'information qui
recevait un agrément du csa
vous pouvez pas me réduire cela a
maintenant le temps d'antenne des
politiques est respecté à la veille de
la présidentielle donc je vous demande
concrètement si ça se fait tout seul
si c'est monsieur bolloré qui vous
demandent de favoriser cela ou si c'est
vous puisque lui dit qu'il n'y est pour
rien
qui intervenait sur le contenu éditorial
pour favoriser le fait que c'est une
chaîne d'opinion et de plus en plus
d'opinions 10 des extrêmes et dangereuse
pour la république
alors parlons je reviens sur vos propos
nous n'avons jamais
jamais manqué de respect sur le temps de
parole nous avons toujours respecté le
temps parole à toute période sur toutes
les périodes vous parlez que de la
quinte dernière quinzaine je le répète
sur toutes les périodes écoulée nous
n'avons jamais eu un problème de respect
du temps de parole voilà à au moment où
les périodes étaient écoulées
le le sujet quand même sur sur ces news
répondre à mes questions là je vous hais
les chaînes d'opinion avec d'opinion et
le concrètement je vais le faire n'a pas
un observateur qui considère
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une chaîne
d'opinion est dit est réalisé dans un
certain sens dans sa réponse justement
les observateurs vous avez indiqué
vous-même long de la session l'audition
de thomas bonheur que vous regardiez pas
ses news donc je me fie aux observateurs
qui regardent la chaîne pour moi c'est
pas une chaîne d'opinion on part d'une
situation de 33 millions d'euros de
déficit en 2016 c'est ça la situation de
ces news pourquoi ces news est dans
cette situation parce qu'on a le record
du monde du 200 chaînes d'information
gratuites
avec un passage de lci en clair dont on
s'écrit pas complètement la nécessité
est derrière la chaine france info qui a
été créée quatre chaînes gratuites plus
toutes les chaînes où l'information est
reprise qui n'ont fait qu'aggraver le
déficit de cette chaîne prendre 3
millions
d'euros moi je je je vais revenir sur
vos parcours peut-être mais je suis pas
un idéologue je suis un gestionnaire je
pense que c'est pour ça que j'ai été
recruté par vincent bolloré
33000 nos déficits c'est pas possible
c'est pas durable c'est pas pérenne on
parle de diversité on parle de
pluralisme si toutes les chaînes
d'information disparaît sous toutes les
chaînes d'informations privées on a un
problème
32 millions de pertes à l'époque pour
lci donc je dirais la situation humaine
nature notre réflexion et
comment est-ce qu'on résorber ce déficit
est le sujet pour nous c'est de se
différencier sur un marché qui est
pléthorique
le sujet l'analyse qu'on fait c'est con
à bfm qui est sur un positionnement de
breaking news qu'on n'a pas la capacité
de suivre parce qu'il est très coûteux
et vous savez bfm est la seule un chat
un chat d'informations privées rentable
et ils font un travail remarquable j'ai
absolument pas de critiques à apporter à
cette chaîne et nous notre souhait c'est
de nous différencier et donc on parle
dans une logique de durée d'ecoute en
disant on va pas pouvoir faire du
breaking news et d'informations brutes
aussi aussi aussi aussi clairement que
le fai bfm et donc on va aller dans une
durée d'ecoute dans une logique de durée
d'ecoute pour que les téléspectateurs
restent davantage et pour générer du
revenu publicitaire et donc à partir de
là en partie sur une notion de débat qui
est la réalité du positionnement
éditorial aujourd'hui vous vous dites
chaînes d'opinion moi je dis non donc je
réponds clairement à votre à votre
question c'est une chaîne de débats où
toutes les opinions avons vocation à
s'exprimer c'est ça la réalité et c'est
bien pour ça que le succès de ces news
est arrivé parce que il ya des opinions
qui se sont retrouvés sur cette chaîne
parce qu'elles étaient exprimées et
potentiellement ne l'était pas ailleurs
quand vous avez un positionnement sur la
durée avec des opinions qui sont toutes
les opinions qui sont représentés à
l'antenne et ben vous avez des
téléspectateurs qu'il les entend n'est
pas qui tout d'un coup se retrouve
notre stratégie de ce point de vue là
est très clair et je comprends et vous
l'avez dit vous êtes gestionnaire donc
vous vous essayez aussi de développer
les parts d'audience sur l'ensemble des
médias et donc ses news on comprend les
problématiques de gestion mais comprenez
qu'il ya pas non plus que des
problématiques de gestion quand on
dirait jamais dire
le le comité d'éthique structure interne
à canal+ émis des
réserves des remarques sur l'émission
face à l'info en préconisant un
changement de format et en demandant qui
est un contradicteur par rapport à
l'intervenant principal qui était en
l'occurrence eric zemmour vous n'avez
pas suivi les recommandations du comité
d'éthique d'abord qui a pris la décision
de ne pas suivre le comité d'éthique et
pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas suis
alors d'abord le comité d'éthique et si
vous aussi vous interroger chacun de ses
membres et vous le dira contre quelle
nous l'a dit à nous il a dit au csa les
relations avec le comité d'éthique sont
fréquentes et ils nous ont indiqué au
même camp en discutant en échangeant
avec d'autres membres d'autres comités
éthiques qu'ils avaient le sentiment
d'être le comité d'éthique le plus
sollicité et le plus actif à paris
ils nous ont fait un certain nombre de
recommandations
la première c'était d'introduire du
différé nous avons suivi cette
recommandation
donc il ya bien une recommandation qui a
été suivie
jeu nettement je n'ai pas souvenir d'une
recommandation qui n'a pas été suivi sur
la contradiction donc nous considérons
que précisément il y a eu
systématiquement contradiction en face
d'eric zemmour avec de nombreux
ministres les intellectuels de tous
rangs des
ddd des politiques de tous horizons
des chefs d'entreprise
donc je ne me souviens pas qu'on n'ait
pas suivi de recommandations mais en
tout cas pour nous la contradiction
existe et est pour répondre à votre
question c'est moi qui prends ces deux
décisions l'occurrence c'est moi qui
l'ait prise donc si j'ai bien compris
vous avez plus précisément mais vous
avez quand même dit quelque chose qui
est assez intéressant fait donc vous
n'êtes pas une chaîne d'opinion mais
vous vous dites on n'est pas une chaîne
d'information mais une chaîne de débats
vous n'avez pas reçu d'agrément du csa
pour être une chaîne de débats
premièrement donc vous êtes une chaîne
d'information et ensuite la question du
pluralisme vous dit en gros vous le lier
à
votre statut de gestionnaire vous dites
nous il faut fauqué du public il faut
que ce soit rentable et donc en gros on
a choisi de faire du trash en termes
dîner parce que ça ça permet de faire de
l'audimat et donc vous n'avez pas été
organisées du débat de société qui
permet d'éclairer les citoyens mais vous
avez été chercher ceux effectivement qui
n'était pas sur les plateaux mais pour
cause parce qu'en république on ne met
pas sur les plateaux impunément des gens
qui prônent le négationnisme ou de
théories racistes qui ont provoqué
beaucoup de morts aux etats unis comme
celle du grand remplacement
et je peux vous citer les noms
et quand il y à l'information d'une
tribune de valeur actuelle de 1000
militaires qui disent des choses assez
dangereuse et controversés en tous les
cas on ne fait pas un plateau avec 90%
de ceux qui sont là qui soutiennent ce
type de démarche donc je m'appuie sur
des choses précises genou n'a pas le
temps ici de vous parler de chaque chose
mais en ce qui concerne votre propre
responsabilité donc vous m'avez pas
répondu et je note qu'après monsieur
bolloré qui disait que c'était vous qui
savez vous botter en touche alors que
tout le monde sait que aujourd'hui il y
en a pour qui c'est juste c'est bien son
coup temps et il y en a d'autres noms
que votre chaîne d'information et très
connoté sur le plan idéologique comme
aucune chaîne d'information qui chacune
à c'est effectivement des tendances dans
la façon de traiter l'information
aucune aujourd'hui n'est sur ce créneau
est en tous les cas n'existe pas dans
les conventions avec le csa est
aujourd'hui d'art comme la possibilité
d'avoir des chaînes d'opinion dans les
fréquences attribuées il y en avoir sur
le numérique sur sur internet ça existe
chacun peut même faire sa chaîne mais ça
n'est pas prévu et c'est bien comme ça
après les licenciements de sébastien
thoen pour son ska tueur pascal praud et
celui de stéphane be pour l'avoir
soutenu
la presse raconte qu'une quinzaine de ça
et on souhaitait vous rencontrez fin
janvier 2021 oui
un participant résume si votre rencontre
il nous dit qu'il comprend notre
souffrance et nous jure qu'il n'y aura
pas de chasse aux sorcières parle de
vous
mais le lendemain alors que vous
encensez le 10 février vous réitérer
cette promesse lors d'une
visioconférence avec la rédaction et
vous encensez l'émission dimanche soir
sport de laurie delhostal le lendemain
la journaliste qui n'a pas plus que j'ai
connu pour sa franchise est déprogrammée
licenciés vous la veille vous disiez
qu'il n'y aurait pas de problème pouvez
vous nous expliquer pourquoi est-ce
comme pour monsieur sébastien thoen où
vous aviez indiqué à ce dernier qu'il
est viré sur décision de l'actionnaire
dire que vous comprenez la souffrance
des gens est debout dit mais moi je n'y
peux rien c'est l'actionnaire est
l'actionnaire dit que lui ne décide de
rien c'est vous qui décidez
et vous avez assumé sur rmc quand on n'a
plus envie de bosser quelque part on
prend ses responsabilités on a demandé à
d'autres de partir parce qu'on a envie
de travailler avec des gens qui veulent
travailler avec nous je suis désolé mais
c'est comme ça
que me répondez vous sur ce fait précis
mais bon j'en ai tellement d'autres oui
je suis d'accord il y en a tellement je
sais pas par où commencer
vous avez dit que j'avais dit que ces
news n'est pas une chaîne d'information
je m'inscris en faux j'ai jamais dit ça
j'ai dit que c'était pas une chaîne
d'opinion
vous qualifiez de trash une chaîne que
vous n'avez jamais regardé cet
inquiétant
c'est inquiétant pour les 100
journalistes juste il y au point c'est
pas une chaîne que je regarde
régulièrement comme cantona ou le média
préféré ne venait pas essayer d'avoir de
polémique et moi là dessus je regarde ce
que je veux par contre je peux vous dire
que moi personnellement comme homme
politique et publique j'ai pris la
décision depuis le grand nettoyage que
vous avez fait est que deux avaient
quitté les autres passages à ses news et
depuis le fait qu'il ya cette tendance
là de ne répondre à aucune invitation de
ses new skies le sait très bien et je
n'ai pas mis les pieds sur votre plateau
mais c'est la course à présent on va
lancer répondre de ce stade
laisse répondre monsieur ça messieurs
vous changez d'avis nous serons ravis de
vous recevoir
la chronologie vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure et inexact
constance et l'émission dimanche soir
sport non je n'ai pas fait ce inexactes
j'aimais bien les missions il
fonctionnait pas et donc on la
déprogrammer c'est une décision comme il
y en a beaucoup vous pointez celle là il
y en a beaucoup d'autres
sébastien thoen
a été rémunéré par un tiers pour
dénigrer canal+ c'est un problème pour
moi je l'assumé c'est une décision que
j'ai prise
je ne me dérobe pas comme vous l'avez
semblez le dire tout à l'heure
stéphane guy avait fait l'objet de
nombreuses nombreuses alertes sur son
comportement à l'antenne où il avait
tendance à exprimer son opinion
personnelle pendant les matches pendant
des émissions on lui disait que c'était
un sujet et c'était la fois de trop en
effet il intervenu sur ce sujet
spécifique du décès d ailleurs pas un
licenciement parce qu'ils étaient pas en
cdi au passage sébastien thoen il était
pigistes donc c'était une fin de
collaboration
comme vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure
qu'on avait débarqué des
collaborateurs de ses new skies n'est
pas le cas puisque en fait nous avons eu
recours à une rupture conventionnelle
qui était leur choix le choix la demande
des salariés concernés qui ont eu trois
semaines pour se positionner choisir un
plan de départ
alors qu'on avait la possibilité
d'exercer une cause de confiance les
intéressés eux mêmes n'avaient pas
souhaité que nous exercions la clause de
confiance enfin exercer leurs clauses de
confiance
et nous avions mis en place avec le
ministère du travail cette rupture
conventionnelle pour pour les 78
salariés concernés
donc oui j'assume totalement la décision
sur sébastien thoen la décision de
stéphane dit c'est moi qui l'ait prise
et pourtant j'étais attaché à ce
journaliste
qui a énormément de qualités par
ailleurs
dernière question du rapporteur après
mes collègues interviennent questions
plus générales sur havas
pouvez vous préciser les rapports de
votre groupe avec havas et je vais vous
dire le jeu vous dit de la série de
petites questions concrètes qui vont
avec que répondez-vous aux accusations
de favoritisme
visant l'activité d'havas ce avec les
chaînes de votre groupe l'agent saurait
en effet tendance à favoriser canal+ et
ses filiales ses huit ses stars et ses
news en 2018 ces chaînes ont représenté
12 1% des espaces publicitaires achetés
par havas alors qu'elle ne pesait que
neuf chez les agences concurrents qu'on
est il de l'achat d'espacés
publicitaires par le groupe canal+ et
opérations pastel exclusivement par
havas
havas analyse les données qu universal
music group ancienne propriété du groupe
vivendi et ses artistes génère au
travers de la vente de leur musique de
leurs ventes de billets des produits
dérivés du streaming des médias sociaux
d écoute radio afin de mieux appréhender
la corrélation entre les artistes les
fans de musique et les marques les
données clients du groupe canal + sont
elles utilisées par abbas en vue de
développer une offre publicitaire mieux
ciblés voilà une question sont très
précises
excusez moi monsieur le rapporteur je
n'ai pas compris la question sur umg
universal music
havas analyse les données de
qu'universal music group ancienne
propriété du groupe vivendi mais où est
encore d une départ et ses artistes
génère au travers de la vente de leur
musique de la vente des billets des
produits dérivés du streaming des médias
sociaux les écoutent radio afin de mieux
appréhender la corrélation les artistes
les fans de musique et les marques je
vous pose la question les données
clients du groupe canal sont elles
utilisées par havas en vue de développer
une offre publicitaire mieux cibler
très bien très clame ainsi alors sur les
12 1% le chiffre que vous indiquez
totalement exact c'est bien la part de
marché du groupe canal + chez havas et
elle est exactement de même nature chez
tous ses concurrents à l'exception de
publicis dont nous avons le sentiment
qui le nous punit parce que havas fait
partie du groupe lui vingt dix et que
canal + fait partie du groupe des vingt
dix c'est un sujet dont je me suis
entretenu à plusieurs reprises avec
arthur sadoun notamment où nous avons
une part de marché plus tôt 2 9% mais
chez les autres me com et où je pourrais
citer toutes les agences est de l'ordre
de 12%
donc nous n'avons pas du tout le
sentiment pour être précis défavorisés
par havas au passage on parle de 34
millions d'euros sur les douze derniers
mois
versé en revenus publicitaires issus
d'abbas pour le groupe canal + 0 6 % du
chiffre d'affaires de canal+ donc un
chiffre assez dérisoire et
accessoirement un chiffre en baisse
puisqu'il était de 38 millions l'année
précédente
et pour répondre également précisément à
votre question sur l'utilisation des
données par abbas ce n'est pas le cas
canal+ exploite directement ces données
et quand il les partage avec des
partenaires il est d'ailleurs tenu
d'indiquer à ses à ses abonnés si on le
faisait ça serait indiquée et il
faudrait que nous y soyons autorisé par
les abonnés
jean raymond ouellet
merci président bonjour monsieur saddam
même si une certaine tension est à peine
palpable dans cette salle rené monory
ancien
chapelle
je vais peut-être amené plus de 2 calme
en rapport avec ce que sont les
commission denquête au sénat
si j'osais je dirais que votre formation
votre parcours que vous avez rappelé au
début parce que chez un professionnel
c'est important
ce parcours atteste non pas d'un point
de vue alors là je devrais sans apporter
la contradiction notre rapporteur mais
ce n'est pas un point de vue à mon sens
puisque c'est exactement ce que sont
venus nous dire tous les industriels
tous les entrepreneurs et ce n'est pas
un gros mot
devant cette commission d enquête depuis
le début des auditions vous êtes venu
nous dire au début de votre propos les
mécanismes les réalités concrètes et
incontournable de l'économie mondiale
avec laquelle vous vous débattez avec
canal+ vous êtes la preuve vivante et
c'est important et ô combien
rassurant
que le défi de la taille
est un défi qui peut être relevé par la
france si jamais c'est un défi national
et ça non plus c'est pas un gros mot
devant ces plateformes qui nous arrive
en leur ouvrant les portes comme vous
l'avez décrit où certains pouvoirs ont
favorisé l'arrivée de ces plateformes au
détriment d'entreprises françaises
mais pour parvenir à cette à ce maintien
d'activités il s'agit pas d'être figée
dans le temps sur des combats d'arrière
garde et j'ai l'impression souvent nous
sommes dans ces combats en france il
s'agit de se concentrer sur ce qui fait
ce business et ce n'est pas un gros mot
la partie technologie et la partie
contenue
en citant les slogans puisque c'est au
coeur du débat j'ai l'impression les
slogans de ces news la liberté d'opinion
est elle une espèce en voie de
disparition
ou c'est en confrontant les opinions
qu'on s'en fait une ma première question
c'est quelle est votre conception du
rôle de l'actionnaire principal dans un
média et la seconde et j'en aurai
terminé par la pouvez-vous préciser aux
législateurs que nous sommes les freins
principaux et dieu sait s'ils sont
nombreux qu'il faudrait lever pour
permettre aux acteurs français de faire
valoir notre exception culturelle
et ce avec quoi nous rayonnons depuis
des siècles alors que nous sommes grands
comme un timbre-poste à la surface du
globe
merci
le sénateur
le rôle de l'actionnaire principal dans
un média tels que j'ai vécu - c est un
drôle de vision
vision partagée avec vincent bolloré
de la capacité pour un acteur français
de rayonner de faire rayonner la culture
française européenne à l'international
et 2,7 au port du jeans marché que
j'évoquais dans mon propos liminaire
cette volonté de faire rayonner la
culture de croire en la culture et en sa
force et comme une alternative est la
seule alternative en réalité aujourd'hui
crédible face à l'hégémonie culturelle
américaine qu'on aime beaucoup par
ailleurs qu'on consomme aussi
et qu'on regarde également
donc ça c'est la première chose c'est
une conviction partagée et cette volonté
construire un acteur industriel qui pèse
au plan mondial
et qui fait rayonner notre culture nos
talents notre histoire nos lieux
dans laquelle nous investissons plus en
plus via studio canal ou via un canal +
et et localement dans tous les
territoires européens et j'ai cité
la deuxième la deuxième chose pour moi
la deuxième vertu j'ai envie terre de
l'actionnaire pour de mon point de vue
de salariés
c'est ce qu'a évoqué vincent bolloré
lors de son audition ici c'est le temps
le temps qu'ils nous aient laissé la
chance qu'on a chez kana plus de ne pas
être soumis comme d'autres
à la règle quotidienne ou quasi
quotidiennes du cours de bourse qui peut
motiver des décisions dans un sens ou
dans l'autre et cette possibilité de
s'inscrire dans une durée plus longue
elle est absolument crucial
elle nous permet de faire des
investissements dans le long terme elle
nous permet de résister à des événements
ponctuels avec cette vision d'une durée
plus longue elle nous permet de prendre
des risques
financer un film ces trois ans financé
une série versailles que c'était tout à
l'heure le bureau des légendes ses 5 ans
donc il faut s'inscrire dans cette durée
et c'est une chance
pendant la deuxième question vous
m'aviez posé
pouvez vous préciser aux législateurs
que nous sommes les freins principaux
qu'il faudrait lever pour permettre aux
acteurs français de faire valoir nos
merci il y en a beaucoup mais il y en a
un qui me qui est un sujet pour moi sur
lequel je reviens à sa ble ment depuis
j'en parlais déjà en 2016 c'est notre
capacité enfin notre incapacité à
détenir les droits audiovisuels
voilà nous on est toujours dans la même
situation hélas la nouvelle loi
audiovisuelle a conforté les producteurs
ou cette situation dans laquelle nous
finançons entre 80 et 90% de fiction et
nous ne laisserons pas les droits qui
sont réservées aux producteurs est ce
qui nous pose deux sujets le premier qui
est de notre capacité à offrir en france
même sur les marchés où nous finançons
ces séries des droits un peu plus long
c'est bon la durée de ces droits étaient
encore réduite avec la nouvelle loi de
visuels donc on peut se retrouver dans
une situation situation pardon ce qui
nous est arrivé dans le passé ou au
moment où vous proposez la saison 3 du
bureau des légendes vous n'avez plus la
saison un endroit et vous devez la
racheter et potentiellement
refinancer une série que vous avez déjà
financé
mais surtout ça rend beaucoup plus
compliqué cette ambition que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure de faire rayonner la
culture française parce que comme nous
ne détenons pas les droits des séries
que nous finançons en france pour les
territoires de france on se retrouve
dans une situation où aux états unis par
exemple versailles est un netflix le
budget non
et
donc nous ne pouvons pas exploité ses
séries à l'international où il faut pour
le faire se contorsionner trouver des
accords par ailleurs et c'est très très
très compliqué ça c'est vraiment le
premier frein pour le groupe canal+ qui
se retrouve dans une situation hélas
unique parce que c'est le seul opérateur
français je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
même européen à avoir cette ambition
globale mondiale cette présence sur 50
pays donc en fait c'est pas la
problématique de des groupes tf1 m6 ou
même france télévisions qui sont sur
d'autres enjeux
monique de marco
merci
merci monsieur saâdane donc je ne
reviendrai pas sur les inquiétudes que
suscite la ligne éditoriale de beauchêne
mais je rappelle quand même que jean
christophe thiery directeur de la
publication de ces news a été condamné
pour condamnation à la haine raciale et
votre chaîne ces news a reçu une amende
de plus de deux cent mille euros par le
csa pour incitation à la haine et à la
violence je reviens plus tôt sur les
propos que vous avez tenus à la fin de
votre introduction
donc effectivement vous avez considéré
qu'il y avait beaucoup de freins qui ne
fallait pas entraver davantage donc
donc les médias mais également vous avez
terminé en disant que vous considérez
qu'il que c'est une hypothétique
concentration
c'est votre conclusion vous n'avez pas
le cette hypothétique concentration des
médias en france ça pouvez-vous préciser
ses propos
alors sur le premier point je vais me
permettre de revenir sur la décision que
vous citez nous la contestons conseil
devant le conseil d'état
je crois avoir évoqué dans vos propos
liminaire le fait qu'en fait en réalité
le marché était aujourd'hui beaucoup
moins concentrés qu'ils ne l'étaient
dans le passé
beaucoup beaucoup moins le pluralisme on
y contribue d'ailleurs largement
canal+ est aussi distributeur de chaînes
je le rappelle est même un des
principaux en france et à
l'international et pour la france nous
distribuons près de 330 chaînes dont
toutes les chaînes d'information
françaises internationales européennes
la bbc cnn mais aussi toutes les chaînes
françaises y compris ivan iv france 24
et d'autres chaînes d'information donc
nous contribuons largement au pluralisme
et dans la mesure où toutes ces chaînes
existent que de nouvelles sont créées
régulièrement
et que sur chacune de ces chaînes d
exprimant diverses des opinions diverses
s'expriment
je ne vois pas en réalité la
problématique de concentration
poser problème
pour ce qui est du marché français
je voudrais rappeler aussi pardon que on
parle beaucoup de l'information et de
l'accès à l'information il faut rappeler
quand même qu'en france
les chaînes d'information comme source
d'information
ces 16%
le total de toutes les chaînes
d'information 16%
cas pour 46% sont les chaînes
hertziennes
c'est à dire en gros principalement les
13 heures et les 20 heures de tf1 et
france télévisions et le jt de m6 qui
est qui est un succès c'est ça dont on
parle ça c'est 46% des sources
d'information pour la population
française et ensuite vous avez à peu
près un tiers donc deux fois les chaînes
d'information au total qui vient
d'internet dont on n'a pas encore parlé
ici qui est quand même le vrai sujet et
roula on pourrait se poser des question
de concentration si je peux me permettre
quand on a deux acteurs qui détiennent
90% 95% du marché publicitaire
si on prend les jeunes qui est un sujet
je pense qui nous concerne toutes les
moins de 35 ans les chaînes
d'information c'est moins de 13% hélas
les sources internet pèse pour 60 %
60% des sources d'information pour les
jeunes sont un sujet dont on n'a pas
parlé depuis depuis le début de cette
audition et sa paume là pour moyens
sujet éventuellement
michel laugier merci monsieur le
président monsieur s'est dit bonjour
merci pour la réponse très directs qui
sont les vôtres depuis les débuts vous
exprimez votre opinion je veux pas
exprimer la mienne je suis pas là pense
puisque l'objet de notre commission
c'est de vous questionner dont je vais
être direct et je vais passer à mes
questions on a beaucoup parlé bien sûr
de la croissance des médias nous depuis
plusieurs semaines déjà qui entraîne
bien sur deux enjeux l'enjeu économique
bien sûr et puis non je bien sûr
de l'information de la liberté de
l'information du pluralisme
à propos de l'information justement
quelle est la part fait que repas sont à
l'information au sein droit de groupes
en pourcentage par rapport par exemple
au
aux heures d écoute de votre groupe que
représente aujourd'hui l'information
combien de journalistes travaillent pour
peaux de groupage par pack de ces news
pour pour votre groupe est ce que ce
sont des effectifs qui sont stables qui
sont évolutifs et puis est ce qu'il ya
un taux de rotation importants ou es ce
que vous avez une certaine de stabilité
ça c'est ma première question la jane je
voudrais revenir un petit peu quand même
sur
les sanctions ou les où les rappels à
l'ordre du csa aujourd'hui art comme
vous avez eu plusieurs
quelles dispositions avez vous prises
aujourd'hui pour la limite soit rentré
dans le rang soit contesté puisque j'ai
bien compris que certaines étaient
contestées et puis vous avez évoqué d
aller le faire envoyer la question aussi
des grandes plateformes justement on est
aujourd'hui dans un monde des médias qui
a largement évolué quelle est votre
stratégie pour les prochaines années
justement par rapport à cette
concurrence avec les plateformes
internationales
merci à vous
entends l'antenne pour votre première
question je ne saurais pas vous dire on
a
soixantaine de chaînes en france payante
et met à linthal internationale c'est
beaucoup plus est
ces news est la seule chaîne
d'information du groupe donc je dirais
que ça pèse sans doute pour moins de 1 %
en nombre de journalistes donc pour les
cartes de presse de ses new skies on
parle de 120 c'est une centaine pour la
rédaction des sports de canal plus
et nous avons beaucoup de journalistes
sur nos territoires à l'étranger je ne
saurais pas vous dire combien non plus
sur le sujet de la conformité alors
évidemment nous nous nous cherchons à
évidemment respecter
notre convention et
être conforme à toutes les règles
avec le csa et donc nous nous équipons
ce qui était le cas sur le temps de
parole qui est un travail considérable
par une équipe qui est dédié à temps
plein à ce sujet là
je veux dire c'est le sait le rôle de
thomas boddaert que vous avez rencontré
de toutes les équipes de ces news de
chercher à se conformer mais je sais que
ça prend un temps considérable et
d'ailleurs ça parce que je ne critique
en rien puisque pour je sais que pour le
serrer pour l'art comme c'est un sujet
extrêmement compliqué également
sur les grandes plateformes
le
je me souviens d'un d'un déjeuner avec
dominique boutonnat qui venait d'arriver
au cnc qui disait il ya quelques années
il ya cinq ans peut-être quatre ans
leleu la bataille de la distribution est
perdue
focalisons-nous sur la bataille de la
production
et je crois qu'il a changé d'avis depuis
nous nous avons considéré que la
bataille de la distribution elle était
elle était jouable je dis pas qu'on va
la gagner il s'agit pas pour nous de
battre netflix s'agit pas pour nous de
battre amazon c'est pas possible
il s'agit pour nous de coexister il
s'agit pour nous de trouver un modèle
alternatif qui fonctionne qui a du
succès et qui nous permet de pérenniser
le groupe canal+ et tous les
financements qu'ils apportent toute la
contribution qu'ils apportent à la
contribution à la création pardon
française en particulier aux européennes
comme monsieur le rapporteur l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure sur le cinéma c'est ça
l'enjeu pour nous c'est pérenniser ses
investissements et et nous pensons que
le modèle passe beaucoup par cette
nécessité d'être d'avoir une taille
critique et de se développer à
l'international parce que on a dit tout
à l'heure le groupe canal+ a retrouvé
une économie et des résultats mais je
voudrais insister sur le fait qu'en
france on a amélioré la situation parce
qu'on perdait comme j'ai 10 452 millions
d'euros sur deux ans mais on est
péniblement à l'équilibré et encore ça
dépend des années
on est vraiment sur la ligne de crête en
france on peut pas dire que le marché
domestique et je dois dire que l'on n'a
pas trait était très aidée honnêtement
le disais tout à l'heure sur le normatif
soit un marché attractif pour canal+ je
les dis dans mon propos liminaire tout
tous les résultats d'exploitation du
groupe canal+ se font à l'international
soit via la télévision payante
soit via un studio canal et donc nous
sommes encouragés à continuer à nous
développer et je le disais tout à
l'heure nous avons la chance d'avoir un
actionnaire qui nous soutient et qui est
prêt à accompagner ce développement qui
nécessitent des investissements
nous avons une équipe de stratégie et de
finances qui est qu'ils dédient qui
consacrent une part et notre patron de
l'international qui consacrent une part
très significative de leur temps à la
recherche d'opportunités de pays dans
lesquels nous pouvons nous pouvons nous
lancer en organique comme nous l'avons
fait en ethiopie récemment nous avons
déjà vingt-cinq mille abonnés avec une
situation que vous connaissez quelqu'un
qui est très compliqué là sur place
comme nous l'avons fait au myanmar il ya
quelques années également situation
compliquée mais nous regardons
constamment des possibles et de se
lancer dans de nouveaux marchés de
manière organique ou de réaliser des
acquisitions des opérations qui nous
permettent d'aller plus vite dans ce
déploiement à l'international
j'ai annoncé mon au moins 30 millions
d'abonnés pour 2025 j'espère que nous
atteindrons un chiffre supérieur
mais je dois dire qu'à partir de 30 ou
40 millions c'est qu'on peut résister 1
et flix même s'il atteint 300 millions
sylvie robert
bonjour monsieur saada
vous avez commencé par nous dire que
puisque c'est nous ne ne représentait
que 0,4 pour cent du groupe canal
finalement vous ne vous ennuyez pas
énormément
comme on a déjà eu et monsieur bolloré
qui nous l'a dit heureusement dans le
débat avec mes collègues vous venez de
démontrer que finalement vous en occuper
et vous en occuper parce que vous êtes
un gestionnaire et vous avez dis très
clairement je reprends mes propos c'est
intéressant de venir en fin d'audition
comme ça que pour justement émerger
c'est à dire pouvoir en tout cas gagné
de l'argent on va le dire comme ça il
fallait différenciant
et que du coup ses news je dis
exactement ce que vous avez dit il
fallait qu'elle se différencie
vous avez parié sur la durée d'ecoute
pour générer de la pub
vous avais même parlé de deux chaînes de
débats moi je considère que un débat il
ya du contradictoire or sur ces news que
je regarde de temps en temps je n'en
vois guère alors je voudrais vous poser
une question très simple parce que c'est
là qu'on va pouvoir déceler vraiment la
ligne éditoriale quelle distinction
faites vous entre opinions et
informations ma deuxième question
êtes vous favorable à la reconnaissance
juridique des rédactions
c'est un sujet qu'on a beaucoup abordé
parce que la question de la
concentration verticale nous y amène
donc je voudrais précisément votre
voilà votre point de vue sur sur cette
question là et enfin dernière question
troisième question vous avez eu un
accord intéressant avec la chronologie
des médias il ya peu de temps puisque
vous avez signé cet accord et il ya
quelques temps vous aviez annoncé que
vous pourriez faire sortir la chaîne
canal+ de la tnt la faire migrer vers
une plateforme unique
est-ce que c'est toujours d'actualité
est-ce que qu'elle est finalement la
teneur de ses propos et les objectifs
que vous et métiers lorsque vous en avez
parlé à l'occasion
effectivement d'un échange peut vous
avez eue avec
avec des journalistes toujours merci
merci à vous je me permets de revenir
sur ce que je n'ai pas dit que je
m'occupais pas de la chaîne je me dis
que je m'en occupais peu c'est une
question de proportion de temps
j'étais pas demandé je ne vais pas osé
vous demandez combien de temps mais je
pense que là on peut jouer sur sur les
mots mais non merci je crois que
la différence entre
opinions et
l'information dans un cahier des faits
que nous rapportons et dans un autre cas
ya des gens qui s'expriment et qui
donnent leurs opinions leurs analyses de
ces faits
je considère qu'il ya du contradictoire
sur ces news a beaucoup de reprises dans
beaucoup d'émissions
sur la structure juridique honnêtement
je ne sais pas j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya des dispositifs qui prête et protège
les journalistes loi 2016
les délibérations du sessad 2018 les
chartes déontologiques nous avons signé
le comité d'éthique on a évoqué mais je
n'ai pas d'opinion dans un sens ou dans
l'autre sur la structure juridique plus
tu dit à ce sujet je ne sais pas
et d'ailleurs j'en profite pour dire que
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure ça fait 18
ans que chez canal+
n'est jamais un pli un journaliste pour
dire ce qu'il veut dire à l'antenne ou
pas dire à l'antenne
g nous avons eu des discussions très
laborieuse avec les organisations du
cinéma sur la chronologie des médias et
les schémas qui était évoqué au départ
positionner les plateformes américaines
dans ce qu'on appelle la fenêtre de
canal+ terre en concurrence frontale
j'avais le sentiment que cette position
n'était pas défendable pour canal+
vis-à-vis de nos abonnés
et que la proposition de valeur en
réalité de canal+ ne ne serait pas
satisfaisante
si nous nous étions effectivement
retrouvé dans cette situation là
nous aurions dû changer de modèle et
j'ai pas l'habitude de faire des menaces
en l'air j'ai évoqué ce scénario pour
que auprès des organisations pour
qu'elle comprenne cave et qui avait un
sujet pour nous et que nous
n'accepterions pas un schéma dans lequel
les plateformes américaines sur en
frontal avec canal+ le schéma alternatif
que j'envisageais et que je vais
envisager très sérieusement nous avons
fait des études auprès des consommateurs
pour déterminer si ce modèle pouvait
recueillir
de l'intérêt nous avons regardé
juridiquement comment c'était possible
nous avons regardé techniquement comment
c'était possible parce que il ya des
considérations d'offres commerciales
informatiques techniques de diffusion et
cetera et cetera c'était de séparer les
offres de canal+ son cinéma et en sport
la tnt sur le chemin j'y reviendrai mais
mais pas franchement parce que notre
convention tnt c'est une convention de
cinéma de première exclusivité donc en
fait la chaîne canal+ serait devenue une
chaîne de cinémas et potentiellement de
série comme tous nos concurrents qui ont
choisi des modèles séparés et le sport
aurait été sur un autre canal
pourquoi parce que canal plus est dans
une situation unique unique où on a une
chaîne généraliste et que les
obligations vous le savez pour le cinéma
notamment pour le de visuels sont assis
sur l'ensemble du chiffre d'affaires
c'est à dire que quand on dépense plus
de 300 millions d'euros pour la ligue
des champions pour canal+ la ligue des
champions c'est la compétition les plus
populaires sur canal plus et qu'on
recrute des abonnés confie délices des
abonnés et condom congénères du chiffre
d'affaires ce chiffre d'affaires vient
directement nourrir les obligations qui
sont assis sur le jeu de la totalité du
chiffre d'affaires de canal+ dans le cas
d'amazon ils ont fait une offre
distincte avec le pass ligue 1 qui n'est
pas soumis aux obligations c'est
sûrement un sujet global d'obligations
sur amazon mais qui n'est pas et qui ne
sera pas soumis aux obligations toutes
les discussions qui ont lieu avec des
organisations du cinéma où le csa dans
aucune de ces discussions il a été
question d'intégrer le pass ligue 1 dans
les obligations
et donc on se retrouve dans une
situation unique que très peu de gens
souligne parce que c'est que je
considère que c'est un aliment unique de
canal est une vertu absolue du modèle de
canal qui vient financer la création
voilà donc nous aurions nous aurions
séparés soient réduits les obligations
cinéma puisqu'on appliqué à ce moment là
uniquement les obligations sur le
chiffre d'affaires de la chaîne cinéma
et les ressources que cela aurait dégagé
je les aurai réinvesti dans d'autres
thématiques
comme les séries qui sont les
thématiques sur lesquelles toutes les
plateformes américaines vous le savez on
leur a donné le choix entre soit vous
choisissez une un régime cinéma soit
vous choisissez un régime audiovisuel
elles ont toutes choisi le régime
audiovisuels les plateformes netflix ou
amazon ou autres vont privilégier les
investissements dont le visuel ce n'est
pas le cas même plus donc on fait un
modèle différent mais si on nous avait
contraints avec des américains des
plateformes américaines font pas les
citer dans notre plateforme dans notre
fenêtre on aurait donc changé de modèle
evelyne renault garabédian qui est
derrière son écran
line vous entendez
oui très bien
j
vous étiez un gestionnaire le canal plus
n'est pas une chaîne d'opinion mais bien
un lieu de débat et j'en suis tout à
fait d'accord une des signatures de
l'esprit canal a toujours été un certain
type de journalisme il comprit
l'investigation et liberté de ton moi
police x2 chaîne comment le journalisme
d'investigation at il évolué depuis
votre arrivée dans le groupe de canard
merci de vos réponses
alors
le journal d'investigation
on en fait plus sur nos chaînes
d'information et on en fait plus sur
canal+ à quelques exceptions près
pourquoi parce que ça ne fonctionnait
pas si exactement pour les mêmes raisons
qu'on a arrêté un certain nombre
d'émissions en clair on a regardé comme
je le disais tout à l'heure on est dans
une situation où on a perdu 450 millions
sur deux ans et donc on regarde la
contribution des programmes à la
motivation à l'abonnement à la fidélité
de nos abonnés
et nous avons fait le constat que ce
soit dans le cas des émissions en clair
ou dans le cas des
l'étrange d'investigation qu'en réalité
canal+ n'apportait pas suffisamment pour
que ça pour que ces programmes motive à
l'abonnement et je veux dire que ces
thématiques sont couverts par des
chaînes hertziennes gratuites et donc
c'était compréhensible que les abonnés
ne les valorise pas et donc nous avons
mis fin à ce type de programme alors y
est j'ai
entendu parce que mon nom a été cité
dans une des auditions d'ailleurs un
certain nicolas s covaci je crois dire
que j'avais soi-disant ce qui m'a cité
nommément interdit
les les documentaires sur le sport et le
cinéma
d'abord nicolas besco banshee par non
mais je le connais pas
enfin je connais de réputation parce
qu'il parle de moi donc évidemment je
m'intéresse à lui mais j'ai cherché
j'ai cherché
cherché un contrat canal+ pour ce
monsieur j'ai trouvé six jours
d'intermittence en 2010
six jours d'intermittence
je n'ai pas fait de réunion avec lui je
l' ai pas rencontrés
et ce qu'il a dit est faux je n'ai
jamais dit qu'il fallait pas faire de
journalisme d'investigation sur le
cinéma ou sur le sport d'avoir sur
cinéma on m'a jamais proposé de sujets
donc j'ai même pas eu le loisir de
refuser quoi que ce soit
sur le sport j'étais obligé de compter
un depuis que je suis directeur général
de canal+ 2015 on en a fait 25 les
documentaires d'investigation
sur le sport donc je n'aurai pas
beaucoup d'autorité cij avait interdit
aux équipes de faire des documentaires
sur le sport et qu'on en a fait 25
depuis je suis directeur général alors
je pourrais vous les citer mais ça
serait fastidieux
donc
dans ce domaine madame la sénatrice dans
ce domaine il nous est un terreau et il
nous est intéressant est en tout cas nos
abonnés le valorise de faire des
documentaires nous avons fait par
exemple
je ne suis pas un singe
sur le racisme dans le sport dans le
foot en particulier
deux documentaires sur l'homosexualité
dans le sport un documentaire sur la
maternité dans le sport toutes ces
problématiques sociétales et et de leur
impact sur des sportifs de haut niveau
ou des compétitions très valorisé par
nos abonnés nous intéresse et donc il
est tout à fait possible et probable que
nous continuons à développer des
documentaires dans ce domaine
j'ai trois questions relatives à la
stratégie puisque vous inviter à
réfléchir sur la stratégie d'abord et
s'il n'y a pas un paradoxe à distribuer
10 n'est plus et netflix et à s'afficher
officiellement comme leur principal
concurrent sur le marché français c'est
ma première question la deuxième c'est
le rôle que joue dailymotion dont vous
n'avez pas parlé
dans vous occuper la présidence dans
votre stratégie notamment d'affirmations
par rapport aux gars femmes et puis la
troisième je vais revenir sur sur ces
news quand même et on vous avait dit que
c'était epsilon dans votre chiffre
d'affaires on voit bien que dans cette
audition mais pas que dans cette
audition l'image du groupe canal est
maintenant très marquée par ces news et
puis par les
commentaires
suspicion qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir sur
sur 7 sur 7 y est vous qui êtes un
gestionnaire si vous présentez comme tel
et vous avez bien raison de dire est-ce
que franchement ça présente un intérêt
de pour l'ensemble du groupe et pour la
stratégie globale de canal
dead avoir ce positionnement sur ses
news
alors vous avez raison sur le paradoxe
c'est le
dire les américains story of my life mes
concurrents sont mes partenaires ça a
commencé il ya longtemps avec les
fournisseurs d'accès internet qui sont
lancés dans la télévision et qui sont
venus concurrencer le métier un des
métiers historiques de canalsat canal
satellite à l'époque en distribuant des
chaînes voire même comme orange ou sfr
en france ont directement dans
l'acquisition de contenus avec leurs
chaînes mais néanmoins les premiers
distributeurs de canal+ sont sfr ou
aujourd'hui orange free et bouygues
depuis depuis qu'ils ont lancé la
télévision donc on a appris à travailler
avec des potentiels concurrents et
heureusement
moi j'ai toujours considéré que netflix
d'abord je suis consommateur de netflix
mes équipes d'ailleurs me disent qu'il
faut que j'arrête de dire que j'en garde
netflix je le dis trop manifestement
l'enjeu pour nous c'est de satisfaire
nos abonnés est égal à partir du moment
où on considère qu'à des programmes de
qualité sur les plateformes et bien
notre enjeu cd distribués et de les
proposer à nos abonnés pour pas les en
priver donc moi mon sujet numéro un
c'est la satisfaction de nos abonnés et
quand ils me demandent des séries de
netflix il faut que je leur apporte
donc c'est une question de proposition
de valeur et par ailleurs c'est
évidemment pour nous c'était plus
intéressant de les distribuer plutôt que
de les avoir en opposition frontale donc
quelque part nous utilisons leurs forces
pour recruter des abonnés à canal+ qui
viennent alimenter ensuite le chiffre
d'affaires de canal + qui viennent
ensuite alimenter la contribution à la
création que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
et puis nous nous travaillons avec eux
parce que les 19 milliards de netflix
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure où les 33
mineurs de disney c'est aussi un atout
nous avons co produit ou nous
coproduisons avec ces acteurs de manière
régulière des séries je pourrais vous en
citer le prochaine une des prochaines
créations originales événement de canal
+ sera un western spaghetti du nom de
django
que nous coproduisons avec sky et amazon
mais nous avons co produit avec edge bio
avec netflix avec
avec
amazon de nombreuses reprises avec apple
et je pourrais tout sous les sites et
donc est par ailleurs ces gens ces
acteurs convaincus d des
consommateurs de payer pour des contenus
et moi mon sujet numéro un c'est le
piratage l'ennemi pour canal+ c'est
banal fixe c'est le piratage sont des
gens qui choisissent de ne pas payer
pour avoir accès à des contenus qui
théoriquement sont payants et qui
pénalise toute la chaîne de valeur et
toute la chaîne de l'industrie
dailymotion vous remercier d'en parler
on est très fiers dailymotion s'inscrit
exactement dans la stratégie que
j'évoquais plutôt de rayonnement
culturel français et européens c'est la
première plateforme mondiale de vidéos
en ligne européenne ces 400 millions de
visiteurs uniques et c'est une
entreprise qui se développe c'est pas
facile on a face à nous des géants mais
qui continue à se développer dont le
chiffre d'affaires croît de jour en jour
dans le nombre de visiteurs croient et
qui se déploie qui est une véritable
plateforme mondiale avec plus de 150
millions par exemple de visiteurs
uniques
sur l'asie en afrique une soixantaine de
millions en amérique du nord c'est
unique pour une plate forme française
alors sur ses news non une image de
canal+ n'est pas marquée par ces news
pour reprendre votre terme j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs des
indicateurs précis
d'évaluation de la marque canal + et son
attractivité et tous ces indicateurs
sont en hausse nous n'avons jamais été
la marque française la plus valorisée
nous n'avons jamais atteint le premier
du classement auprès des jeunes diplômés
donc je ne crois pas non plus que je
n'ai aucun élément qui le démontrent que
la marque canal + soit entachée d'une
quelconque manière par ses news je
pensais au groupe et aux investissements
peut faire le groupe dans d'autres
médias mais
une suspicion qui est générée maintenant
à chaque fois que le groupe investit
dans un autre média en se disant
ligne éditoriale qui est celle de ses
new skies peut être
être celle qui vend être imposées sur
les médias qui peuvent être achetés par
le haut
je le répète un peu de la ligne
éditoriale c'est une ligne de débats je
crois qu'il est assez distinctes de des
autres chaînes du groupe d'ailleurs on
peut pas dire que canal + sa ligne
éditoriale de ce même nature enfin je
veux dire on a fait la démonstration que
où ces huit d'ailleurs pour prendre les
chaînes gratuites ou ou ses stars
mais sur la porter oui alors de deux
petites questions qui viennent compléter
tout ce qui a été posé comme question
par parme est collé bon
vous vous voyez
même si vous restez sur
pour l'affirmation d'un produit
effectivement partagé par beaucoup
monsieur venait de la mentionner
faut résister aux plateformes c'est le
danger vous savez que ici on a beaucoup
agi là dessus on pris
ma proposition de loi qui a été
d'ailleurs consensuelle à
porter le fer sur la question des droits
de la presse avec google et que on est
assez offensif et
j'attache beaucoup d'importance ceci dit
on met en débat ce sujet très important
que vous pouvez pas nier qui est que la
concentration et la verticalité peut
produire des problèmes
pour l'exercice de la démocratie et même
pour la diversité de l'offre culturelle
et de la création
et
votre gros est au coeur de quelque chose
qui est
ou qui suscite beaucoup d'inquiétude
ailleurs le monde de l'édition est en
train d'être très
se faire entendre de façon très forte et
d'ailleurs moi comme rapporteur le
solliciter pour aborder plus amplement
le sujet parce que si on fait un peu le
déroulé il ya le danger sur
l'information mais certains disent il
peut y avoir avec la wass un bouquin
quelconque
qui est poussé et mis en tête de gondole
les droits du bouquin quand il a
eu le succès poussé par par havas et par
la maison d'édition qui a décidé de le
mettre en tête
pour les films et ensuite vous êtes
financer la production et la diffusion
est donc certain solide et si on est
désavantagé dans ce processus et si il
ya trop d'idéologie et que certains sont
poussés même la liberté intellectuelle
qui existe beaucoup canton c'est le
nombre de maisons d'édition qui vont
être tenues c'est s'interroge vous
pouvez pas nous dire qu'il n'y a pas de
sujet en fait que le sujet juste
économiques et commerciales et je vous
pose la question par exemple il ya un
hebdomadaire cette semaine qui a redit
que monsieur vincent bolloré sera
intervenu pour réécrire le scénario de
paris police
1902 le type d'intervention qu'on
soupçonne à cause de cette étendue de 2
deux mamies sur un certain nombre de
deux médias vous avez et je finis vous
avez fait un petit lapsus tout à l'heure
en est rendu compte quand vous avez dit
avec l'actionnaire vincent bolloré
nous a dit ici et on le sait qu'il n'est
plus
actionnaire que c'est son fils est que
lui il est sorti du conseil de
surveillance de vivendi depuis avril
2018 c'est pour ça qu'il nous a dit
arrêtez de me demander à moi moi je suis
je ne suis plus dans la chaîne de
commandement je peux mieux faire donner
des conseils ça me permet de vous
demander quels sont les processus de
relations pour diriger votre groupe avec
avec yannick bolloré c'est à dire son
fils qui va officiellement
avoir l'ensemble du groupe dans quelques
jours
je crois qu'il ya deux types de
questions louis denat 2 donc la première
sur
l'ensemble potentiellement autour de
l'édition
qui capterait
alors d'abord - pardon mais je ne vois
pas de problème en réalité s'il y avait
un livre chez editis qui faisait l'objet
d'une promotion ou plus forte parce que
il est ici croit et que canal + en
capter les droits et on faisait une
série ou un film
est quand même étonnant de nous dire que
c'est un problème je trouvais ça plutôt
une bonne nouvelle encore une fois pour
le rayonnement culturel à
l'international le sujet c'est ce que
canal+ serait susceptible de capter
l'ensemble c'est ça des livres d'editis
et qui potentiellement les autres
acteurs concurrentes canal en seraient
privés mais donc c'est un sujet de
concurrence c'est pas un sujet
pluralisme juste pour comprendre
exactement les deux très bien comme elle
a rangé de production intellectuelle
c'est aussi de pluralisme je comprends
c'est un avantage au près en cure en
ciel qui peut tuer une diversité et qui
peut réduire liberté de création tout
s'apprend et et pour revenir au tout
début de votre intervention je ne nie
pas du tout qu'il ya une question et que
la question que vous posez légitime dans
cette commission
j'ai essayé de vous éclairer que mon
point de vue comme vous l'avez dit mais
4000 je crois ou 5000 livres publiés par
editis par an donc je crois que le
risque que canal+ s'en empare en
totalité est assez faible sachant que
comme je l'évoquais tout à l'heure nous
produisons une dizaine de séries par an
pour la france et une trentaine au plan
mondial par an
elytis a d'ailleurs annoncé récemment un
projet de création autour des droits
audiovisuels
puisqu'il ne détient pas
systématiquement au passage de
l'audiovisuel des oeuvres et et ses
premiers projets ont été annoncés avec
noël qui est une filiale du groupe tf1
et signer france donc pas avec canal+
nous avons nous développons des projets
évidemment accrédités c'est une chance
inouïe d'avoir editis d'environ 10 mais
pape
potentiellement de machettes je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas est dit est ce
aujourd'hui ça c'est sûr et j'ai la
chance de rencontrer régulièrement les
équipes d'editis est en fait qu'est-ce
qui se passe
le plus souvent c'est michel benezit
dans sa patronne qui me dit tiens
regarde ce livre lit ça ça pourrait être
intéressé pour faire une série est ce
que c'est répréhensible je ne sais pas
est ce que c'est une chance pour le
groupe vernis oui
nous avons quatre ou cinq projets aux
gels avec la chaîne havas est dans ce
que j'ai aimé havas je n'interviens pas
dans ces sujets en fait je en réalité je
veux pas que de mon point de vue de
marque notamment les possibilités des
discussions entre les 10 et havas sur la
promotion de certains livres mais je
pense que c'est le rôle d'un bassin de
de promouvoir et ils le font plutôt bien
je veux je rappelle d'ailleurs que havas
canal était client navas bien avant
l'arrivée de vincent bolloré mais des
dix vraiment 10 ou 15 ans moi j'étais en
charge de sable du marketing j'avais
choisi havas et bet5 et quelle agence
historique de canal dont le considère
d'ailleurs comme le répètent à l'envi
que c'est la meilleure agence du monde
publicitaire bien avant l'arrivée de
vincent bolloré
et jeu puisqu'on est sur le sujet de
vincent bolloré c'est toujours
l'actionnaire c'est pas un lapsus
il est actionnaire je crois que vous
avez confondu présidence du conseil de
surveillance et actionnariat il est bien
actionnaires
de vivendi
actionnaire de référence
deuxième question de processus dont qui
rejoint d'ailleurs vient de faire la
transition
paris police nous avons eu un débat
très spécifique donc en fait ce qui a
été dit est erronée pour faire court
d'abord on adore cette série on est ravi
d'avoir la saison de kate en tournage la
saison est un énorme succès j'ai
rencontré mois fabien nury qui est le
créateur de cette série et que j'estime
énormément
on nous a proposé un scénario dans
lequel nous avons considéré que
l'intrigué policière était trop faible
par rapport à l' intrigues politiques et
donc nous avons simplement demandé aux
auteurs de réduire l intrigue politique
et d'augmenter la proportion puisque
c'est une c'est une série à vocation
policière qui vient se substituer à les
séries policières qui se sont arrêtés à
l'antenne de canal+ comme braquo
engrenage donc la vocation première de
cette série étant policière on a
simplement demandé de rembourser poids
de
2,2 de l'intrigué policière
une précision sur votre précision
monsieur vincent bolloré n'a plus de
mandat de décision d'accor donc quand
vous avez dit avec vincent bolloré
l'actionnaire nous décidons et c'est à
nous considérer que vous aviez faire la
puce est gelée relever parce que c'est
bien avec vincent bolloré qui n'a aucun
mandat décision et qui nous à l'itie qui
ne décidez de rien que l'ensemble des
décisions sont prises par vous pour la
gestion du groupe c'est tout je le
confirme oui il nous a quand même
précisé lors de l'audition qui il avait
participé au déjeuner ou eric zemmour
avait été recruté donc il avait bien
participé à la décision ce jour-là une
participation c'est pas tout à fait
participer la décision mais il est tard
il arrive que vincent bolloré soit
présent à la réunion nous parlons des
programmes de canal+ dans mon sac il
dessine
peut conseiller peut donner un avis et
recommandations sais c'est pas une
décision
le cas du comité cinéma par exemple qui
a été cité de multiples reprises c'est
un comité ça a toujours fonctionné comme
ça c'est collégiale et ensuite si ce
comité n'est pas d'accord ce qui
n'arrive quasiment jamais c'est moi qui
prends la décision
c'est pas parce qu'on participe qu'on
dessine
dans son cas précis il est là
si vous dites qu'il n'était pas dans un
rôle de décision en ce qui concerne
zemmour il a conseillé de huy de le
recruter oui non il n'a pas conseillé de
recruter il a dit vous n'aurez regarder
mais émouvant si je peux me permettre il
était en 2014 sur i télé il y avait eu
des sujets moi je n'étais pas en charge
le ca à l'époque il y avait eu 1 on a
même eu un procès avec lui mais c'était
là l'émission d'itélé qui marchait mieux
elle était avec christophe barbier et
nicolas domenach elle était devant bfm à
l'époque donc quand il nous disait mon
regardez c'est pas idiot ou zemmour je
rappelle qui fait quand même
20% d'audience avec ruquier sur france
télévisions pendant cinq ans il est sur
paris première et rtl pendant dix ans
enfin je veux dire voilà c'est une
personnalité c'est un journaliste qui
marche qui fonctionne à l'antenne et
donc on est à la recherche de nouveautés
comme les différenciations et nous
d'ouvrir des émaux et ont gardé - et
pardon mais de notre point de vue ça lui
a donné raison
ça fonctionnait et s qui il donne les
mêmes conseils sur les autres ces
éditorialistes de ses news mais c'est
pas que des éditorial d'abord si je ne
le saurais pas vous dire honnêtement
comme ça mais non il ne s'est pas une
intervention systématique ça n'existe
pas je trouve qu'il ya quand même un
petit sujet aussi pardon parce qu'on
parle beaucoup d'indépendance des
journalistes on a une rédaction de 120
personnes ces gens là c'est des
journalistes se sont pas des
marionnettes on a on parle beaucoup de
zemmour on oublie
laurence ferrari sonia mabrouk pro
christine kelly la plupart de ses gens
son rédacteur en chef de l'émission en
tout cas ils sont patrons de leur
tranche c'est pas vincent bolloré - ou
qui que ce soit qui ait qui appelle
pascal trop où laurence ferrari pour
dire qu'on a invité ça va être un tel ça
marche pas comme ça son gens là sont
responsables ce sont des professionnels
rigoureux et qui avant tous veulent
faire leur travail de manière la plus
rigoureuse possible et qu'il le fond de
mon point de vue parfaitement
merci monsieur saâdane autre édition se
termine merci des réponses que vous nous
avez apporté à nos nombreuses questions
et je n'en ai collègues nous poursuivons
avec une dernière audition pour cette
matinée donc si vous pouvez rester et on
va bien sûr libéré mais chez sal merci à
vous
bien monsieur le rapporteur et chers
collègues nous continuons nos travaux
avec l'audition de monsieur françois
bonnet qui est président du fonds pour
une presse libre monsieur le faucon
président a été fondée en 2019 par les
fondateurs et les associés de mediapart
avec pour mission principale je cite de
défendre la liberté de l'information le
pluralisme de la presse et
l'indépendance du journalisme
pour ce faire vous soutenez
financièrement des médias indépendants
le 14 octobre dernier vous avez lancé
sur internet un appel visant à
développer l'écosystème de la presse
indépendante
le 7 décembre
vous avez publié un article intitulé
concentration des médias l'urgence
d'agir
j'ai hésité parce que je ne sais plus
dans quel vous vous lavez publié de
l'article sur votre site des chorales
nous sommes donc des gisements intéressé
à la fois par votre constat des risques
éventuels liés aux concentrations mais
également par vos propositions
d'évolution je vous propose
l'organisation suivante à savoir 10
minutes de temps de parole et puis après
bien sûr un système de questions
réponses où vous pourrez compléter ce
que vous n'avez pu dire dans le propos
liminaire cette audition est diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du sénat
elle fera également l'objet d'un compte
rendu qui sera publié enfin je rappelle
pour la forme qu un faux témoignage
devant notre commission denquête
seraient passibles des peines prévues
aux articles
434 traits tirés 13 14 et 15 du code
pénal je vous précise également qu'il
vous appartient le cas échéant de nous
indiquer vos liens de vos éventuels
liens d'intérêts ou conflits d'intérêts
en relation avec l'objet de la
commission denquête je vais vous inviter
monsieur bonnet a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure je vous remercie donc je vous donne
la parole pour dix minutes
dames et messieurs les mets des
acteurs
merci pour cette invitation et puis
merci d'accepter d'entendre le font pour
une presse libre ses analyses et ses
propositions dans ce propos liminaire il
va vous sembler peut être un peu général
mais il vise d'abord à expliquer
pourquoi nous avons décidé de créer ce
fonds pour une presse libre dont la
mission première reconnue d'intérêt
général et d'aidé à la liberté et au
pluralisme